hello grammarians broadly we're talking
about irregular verbs but more
specifically today we're going to talk
about the en ending which is why i'm
calling this lecture taken for a ride
because this little en thing so we've
spoken previously about verbs that show
their past tense or their past perfect
or past participle forms by changing
their vowel sound uh like the verb to
sing right present tense sing past tense
past perfect aspect had sung
so some of the words we're going to be
talking about today also have that vowel
change but what's different about them
is that for the past perfect or past
participle form
instead of ed it's en
let me explain the verb to tear right in
it's present tense it's tear i tear this
piece of paper
uh past tense i tore this piece of paper
and in the past perfect it's i had torn
i probably shouldn't have done that i
had notes on that paper
some verbs that fall into the category
of the en past perfect
have regular seeming past tenses so for
example the word show i show him the
book she showed me the book we had shown
them the book
so we're still getting this
sound
same thing goes with prove
present tense prove past tense proved
past perfect proven
same deal for the verb to bite i bite it
bit
i was bitten or it had bitten
the present tense of to ride is ride the
past is road and the past perfect or
past participle is had written or was
ridden as in the horse was written all
around the countryside the verb to eat
works this way present tense eat past
tense ate past participle or past
perfect whose had eaten or was eaten so
i had eaten earlier or the cookie was
eaten by stew the verb speak undergoes
that vowel shift so it goes speak in the
present tense spoke in the past tense
and past participle or past perfect is
spoken
even really weird words like to be and
to go obey this rule the en rule it just
doesn't necessarily look like it
so
to be the past of that is either was
or were
but the past perfect form of that is bin
which is just b with an in ending on it
right
go is the same way so even though go has
a really weird past form
i go
she went
the past perfect or past participle form
is gone
and sure the letters aren't in the right
order but the sound is there gone
irregular verbs are weird there's no
denying it but we can break them down
and they can be understood and you can
learn anything
david out